sur la toiture des locaux d'emmaüs 600
mètres carrés de panneaux
photovoltaïques
ils fournissent l'électricité pour 50
foyers pour une année de consommation
hors chauffage et eau chaude
l'intérêt c'est de produire de
l'électricité en local est de profiter
d'une surface de toiture qui étaient
disponibles pour produire de
l'électricité
cette électricité consommée au plus près
pour les entreprises ou les maisons qui
sont demandeurs
cette énergie verte est né de la
collaboration entre emmaüs
l'association fondée par l'abbé pierre
il y à 70 ans et la fruitière à énergie
qui a moins de deux années d'existence
cette entreprise solidaire d'utilité
sociale a un objectif sauver la planète
eh oui rien de moins en accélérant la
transition énergétique valeurs communes
et pas un centime à débourser le
président d'emmaüs n'a pas hésité c'est
magique parce que ça nous a rien coûté
ni en argent ni en investissement ni en
dossier technique ni on travaille c'est
l'afrique air énergie qui a tout fait je
pense que c'est un système qui est
génial ce sont leurs gestes pour la
planète c'est pas une histoire d'argent
c'est une histoire de symbole on a un
grand grand grand besoin d'une
transition accélérée et c'est aussi nos
objectifs fondamentaux de la de la
fruitière et énergie c'est nous-mêmes
qui investissons sur sur la centrale
nous produisons l'énergie verte et après
on restituera gratuitement la centrale a
maïs l'électricité produite sur le toit
est vendue à edf de l'autre côté de la
rue emmaüs deviendra propriétaire de sa
centrale dans 20 ans